we go to oliv a garden for one of these
dates and on our way out of Olive Garden
we're kind of teasing and bantering and
having fun and you know using our words
and then on the way walking out of the
doors I kind of like kick jump to the
side and I kick and I kick her in the
butt she was not having it she was like
oh no you didn't I do not play like that
I don't want that I don't accept that
never kick me in the butt like that
again and I was like okay I get it I got
get the message to me this says that his
wife is making the rules in his
relationship and he's following probably
yeah I mean like it doesn't sound bad
what he did you know he was messing
around he was kind of playing and she
basically came in and said no you know
probably in an over dramatic way and
then he's like all right okay so I I'll
just go along with